[Música]
momento de hablar de economía aquí en
France 24 en directo América saludo a mi
compañero Jorge Hurtado Jorge muy buenas
noches hablemos de Brasil porque allí
continúa la atención por ese bloqueo de
algunas rutas en los principales estados
de algunos Seguidores del presidente
bolsonaro que no reconocen los
resultados de las elecciones Santiago y
es que esto bloqueo ya comienzan a
afectar la economía interrumpe en la
distribución de combustible y la
producción de carne así como el envío de
granos a los puertos Según dijo hoy el
sector privado las protestas afectan el
principal acceso al puerto de
exportación de granos de para Anáhuac
obstaculizando los envíos desde uno de
los principales productores de alimentos
de todo el mundo también se pronunciaron
los procesadores de aves de corral y de
carne de cerdo que incluso tendrían que
detener operaciones en algunos sitios a
partir de este miércoles Los camioneros
piden una intervención militar para
mantener evolucionar o en el poder
durante su discurso bolsonaro mencio que
las protestas reflejaban la
insatisfacción en el proceso electoral
hablemos ahora de México porque allí las
remesas aumentaron un 15% entre el mes
de enero y septiembre de este año para
darnos una idea México la economía
mexicana recibió
42,964 millones de dólares de sus
connacionales en el extranjero entre
enero y septiembre de este año según el
banco de México las remesas de mexicanos
hacia su país de origen suman ya 29
meses con incrementos sostenidos Durante
los primeros nueve meses del año la
remesa promedio individual fue de 390
dólares eso Es aproximadamente
4,25% más de la media de 374 dólares del
mismo periodo pero de 2021 México sumó
un total de
51,585 millones de dólares en remesa al
cierre del 2021 una cifra récord que
representa un aumento del 27% respecto
al monto recibido durante la pandemia en
el 2020 solamente en Estados Unidos
viven 38 millones de mexicanos las
remesas en México son la segunda fuente
de Divisas después de las exportaciones
automotrices y representa más ingresos
que el sector agrícola en ese país es el
3% del producto interno bruto Jorge
hablemos ahora de algo preocupante el
dólar en Colombia tocó un nuevo máximo
histórico Esto sí que nos afecta el
bolsillo bueno la divisa estadounidense
se negoció entre los 4.886 y los 5000
pesos colombianos las razones del alza
tienen en parte raíz en el contexto
internacional Este martes comenzó la
reunión de la reserva Federal de Estados
Unidos y se espera que mañana se anuncie
otro aumento de los tipos de interés de
75 puntos básicos de esto Depende si el
dólar sigue fortaleciéndose frente a
otras monedas del mundo Aunque la
oposición local culpa al gobierno de
Gustavo Petro de la devaluación Este
martes también se radicó en el congreso
la controversial reforma tributaria que
impulse el presidente Petro Pese a que
se eliminó algunos de los artículos que
más preocupaban al mercado como el
impuesto a las pensiones todavía se
discuten las políticas hacia el sector
de hidrocarburos que es súper importante
para el pib colombiano y mientras sube
el dólar en algunos países el euro cae
nuevamente debajo de la paridad con
respecto al Dólar porque bueno afectado
principalmente por la publicación del
dato del mercado laboral y de la
actividad del sector manufacturero en
Estados Unidos el euro subió y recuperó
el nivel de los 0,99 dólares en las
primeras horas de la de la negociación
europea impulsada por comentarios de la
presidenta del Banco Central Christine
lagarde a favor de más subidas de los
tipos de interés Pese a que la economía
podría entrar en una recesión el aumento
de vacantes en Estados Unidos en
septiembre muestra que ese mercado
laboral está todavía bien y que la
demanda supera el número de desempleados
que buscan empleo esto podría motivar a
la reserva Federal de Estados Unidos a
continuar con agresivas o días de los
tipos de interés cada vez que suben el
tipo de interés Pues los inversores se
van hacia hacia estos mercados
fortaleciendo el dólar y debilitando por
supuesto el resto de monedas del mundo
como el peso colombiano el peso chileno
el peso argentino y e incluso el euro
pasemos ahora a hablar de Estados Unidos
porque también hubo mucha expectativa en
torno a la subida consecutiva de los
tipos de interés en este país sería la
sexta consecutiva a lo largo de este año
y ahí va a ser seguramente el el la
noticia de la semana en economía los
mercados esperan que vuelva a ser de 75
puntos básicos si las previsiones se
cumplen la tasa de interés oficial de la
mayor Economía del mundo pasará a
situarse en el rango de entre 3,75% y el
4% un nivel no visto desde el año 2007
el número de puestos de trabajo
disponibles aumentó a 10,7 millones en
septiembre frente a los 10,3 millones
revisados el mes anterior el persistente
desequilibrio entre la oferta y la
demanda de mano de obra sigue genera un
aumento de los salarios en Estados
Unidos eso suma a las presiones sobre
los precios y refuerza las expectativas
de otra gran subida de tipos de interés
este miércoles según los últimos datos
publicados hace dos semanas por la
oficina de estadísticas laborales de
Estados Unidos la tasa de inflación
interanual bajó por tercera vez
consecutiva en septiembre y se situó en
el 8,2% Aunque esos siglos de consumo
subieron 4 décimas en el balance
intermenstrual hablemos ahora de la
cifra del día para el cierre 8 dólares
eso probablemente te costará Santiago si
quieres tener la cuenta de Twitter
verificada y es parte de los cambios que
elon most ha ido anunciando tras su
llegada y tras la compra también a esta
red social que es la más importante del
mundo según el multimillonario entre los
beneficios que tendría si accedes a
pagar los 8 dólares mensuales está que
los usuarios tengan prioridad en las
respuestas menciones y búsquedas y la
posibilidad de publicar videos y audios
más largos además de que la mitad de los
anuncios que reciben una cuenta que no
paga esta suscripción no la tengo
verificada con el dólar a 5000 tampoco
va a pagar los 8 dólares entonces la
dejo como está Muchas gracias Jorge por
esta actualización a continuación aquí
en directo América el debate
[Música]